we're at the end of the long american
century
our company is a declining empire inside
a declining empire amen brother people
are are
killing themselves with guns or dope so
fast that we're losing pace unsubscribe
hey guys pete here this is my breakdown
of succession season three episode two
there's a lot to talk about with kendall
trying to make his case to his siblings
all in the shadow of their father who
can turn everything upside down just by
sending a box of donuts to their tea
party they're probably safe to eat but
act as a poison reminding everyone of
logan's power over them even when he's
thousands of miles away as a quick
warning this video will contain spoilers
if you haven't watched mass and time of
war yet and with that out of the way
let's get into it in episode 1 we
watched the newly liberated kendall
declare the juices loose baby as he
scrambled to find a place to set up his
operations after his press conference it
ended with his sister shiv telling her
driver there would be a change of plans
after she learned jerry would be named
ceo and we pick up with her on her way
to ken's to open episode 2. we see that
she decides not to answer a call from
logan on the way this sets him off
shouting he needs to know where everyone
is and that he's losing juice there's a
lot that happens on the sidelines this
week jerry is settling into her new role
snapping a picture of the tv
announcement of her promotion so that
she can show it to her daughters logan
told roman to keep an eye on her so he
pays her a visit where she reassures him
that they're okay and that he does have
good instincts sometimes he suggests
putting together an executive committee
which doesn't sound like a terrible idea
and from there his apprenticeship begins
at logan's request marcia makes a return
he's not willing to apologize he can't
eat [ __ ] he just can't do it but she's
open to the idea of standing by her
estranged husband's side for a price
which according to her negotiator will
involve some very very large numbers a
literal trojan horse gets delivered from
stewie who drops by later to facilitate
a call between kendall sandy and his
daughter who's also named sandy but
spelled with an eye they want assurances
that ken can kill his father and if he
can deliver they seem agreeable to terms
that don't involve a shareholder vote we
got a continuation of the trend of
someone saying i love you and not
getting a response only this week's ship
calls tom out on it he eventually does
come around saying it back but at the
same time reduces their relationship to
a financial agreement saying it's good
to know they don't have an unbalanced
love portfolio kendall's new
high-powered lawyer informs him that
they're gonna have to sit down together
for eight to ten hours soon she
pressures him for the documents and
warns him that he could be subpoenaed
that the fbi could show up at any time
and that they might be getting a search
warrant right now he puts her off saying
that he's got bigger fish to fry but we
do see him arrive at her office at the
very end of the episode greg on the
other hand is very focused on his legal
matters he doesn't really want to go to
congress again he's kind of too young to
be in congress so much you know he
consults his legal connections a
first-year law student and then he gets
spooked when a lawyer who says he's been
sent by jerry shows up at his front door
getting pressure from both sides from
the company ann kendall he decides to
turn to his grandfather ewan who agrees
to help him but then when they go meet
the lawyer it starts to feel like gramps
has his own agenda in doing so the
lawyer tells him they're going to expose
the structural contradictions of
capitalism as refined in the
architecture of corporate america and
greg of course he just wants to stay out
of trouble if that's not too selfish and
it's gonna be really interesting to find
out what he's got himself into while all
of this was put together well and
important for how things are going to
develop this episode was really about
kendall getting all the roy children
together and his attempt to get one if
not all of them on his side to try to
finally take his father down
as you might have guessed going in this
doesn't work out i thought that shiv
would come to see him at the end of the
last episode but was a little surprised
that they all came to talk so quickly it
does make sense though considering
they're all opportunists every action is
an attempt to secure their position and
a lot of that is why kendall's approach
seemed so misguided he didn't appear
quite as manic here but he used that
same language where he tries to paint
himself as an agent of change he's the
best candidate because he understands
how evil their father is and he can do
things differently and there's truth in
the evil part and overall this might
work with people he's hiring to work for
him after all they're getting paid to
listen to it whether they believe
there's anything behind it or not and in
that professional arrangement it is
worthwhile to say you're motivated by
the right things but behind closed doors
amongst the family it all just sounds
like empty platitudes to be sure there
are a couple of different things going
on here for one none of the roys
actually care about making a positive
change to the culture of their company
not enough to put themselves at risk
anyway conor seems the most receptive
but it's hard to imagine him following
through with any decisions that would go
against logan roman is the most honest
he flat out admits he doesn't care and
as kendall pointed out earlier in the
episode shibb likes to tell herself
she's a good person but she's not and
all of that is beside the point because
everything kendall's saying is just a
way for him to feel justified in trying
to take over the company you see that on
display after things fall apart none of
what he's saying to his siblings after
they turn him down line up with what
he's supposed to be standing for
especially with the way that he goes
after shiv there are real issues there
real crimes involving marginalized
people that no one's ever gonna get in
trouble for ones that kendall and connor
both willingly admit that they know
about and seeing the roy's tear into
each other the way they go after the
people closest to them tells you all you
need to know about how much they care
about the victims of their company's
crimes the other thing that's going on
is that from a lifetime of abuse the
roys are all afraid of logan back in the
first season the therapist pointed this
out before his unfortunate dive into the
shallow end of the pool and i suppose in
some families that might bring the kids
together against the parent but it has
an opposite effect here you can feel it
throughout the entire conversation as
they lash out at each other and it's
hard to imagine that they'd ever be able
to work together even though they are
able to see that if they did they'd be
able to take their father down i
wouldn't be the first to point out that
the show is really best when you get all
these people in a room together and that
is where this episode shines or at least
it shines a light again on how
dysfunctional these kids are in relation
to their father they each have reasons
to want to take him down and other than
kendall they all have reasons to want
him to stay on top but none of them can
really do anything or even imagine that
they could do anything whenever it
really comes down to it it started to
look like they might come together but
no one was able to get behind the idea
of kendall taking the ceo position they
do have feelings for each other you do
see that come out at different points
but they all seem adverse to the idea of
working under each other unless of
course daddy had told them to so it's
all a bit rough to watch with some
really funny and clever things mixed in
there i really like the inclusion of the
donuts and how that changed everything
also loved how they just showed up
without any setup on logan's end they
just pop up there and they're enough to
send everyone scurrying off in different
directions
at the end logan returns to the states
and they arrive at the airport where
they're photographed by paparazzi marsha
isn't there so i guess her deal hasn't
been finalized yet logan walks right
past jerry like he doesn't see her and
he has tom moved to the front so he can
sit and back with shiv after saying he
was disappointed that she didn't meet
him with a hug on the tarmac he offers
her the position of president which
sounds like something he made up for the
occasion to give them some credibility
going into the shareholder vote when she
asks if that means she's a mascot he
sounds sincere in saying that she'll
have some power she'll be his eyes and
ears but wearing a full chemical and
biological suit going by the name of
jerry kelman which hints that she'll be
the one pulling the strings following
his orders so ship will be there for
logan roman will be there with jerry and
kendall is on his own it all comes down
to the fact that logan is much better at
all of this and even if it's just fear
that is keeping everyone in line he
definitely looks like he's winning the
war at this point this was a fantastic
episode and i can't wait to see where
they go from here as has become standard
there was a ton of tension and i thought
they did a great job tying things
together on the outside on the edges
away from kendall's daughter's room you
know nothing too histrionic or
meretricious a lot of little details and
of course an abundance of great lines
and it's nice to see that everyone's
back in the same place there was no
robba or naomi in this episode and it
makes you wonder how long kendall can
continue to operate out of his ex-wife's
house as i mentioned earlier he does go
to lisa's office at the end of the
episode when he brushed her off earlier
i started to question if he was trying
to hide something but greg seemed to
confirm that he did come through with
the documents when he was trying to
sound like he didn't know anything about
them on the phone with tom i feel like
having those two split up and tom away
from shiv has been taking something away
and am looking forward to seeing them
back together and i think that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you think what you thought
of the episode and where you think
things are going and how about them
donuts stop looking at the [ __ ]
donuts please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon